everything on the internet is not good
oh there's insight that's why you come
to the show because I state the obvious
so profoundly but let me tell you I have
I have made a decision it's like a new
thing this year it's one of my 2016
things I refuse to read comments after
articles the stupid and mean human
beings that post comments after articles
you when you see this stuff on there you
know why some species eat their young I
mean it's just unbelievable that some
people's kids
so about I don't know three four weeks
ago I guess maybe six weeks ago I forget
this art this article was bumping around
the internet when Shawn Cooper paid off
his mortgage in three years he was so
proud he called in a TV crew to film him
burning his mortgage papers sounds like
something we would do with the debt free
stream right but not everyone celebrated
with him in fact the 30 year olds
achievement actually annoyed a lot of
people as the Canadian resident
explained to CBC Cooper managed to
achieve the unbelievable feat simply by
being frugal said he worked three jobs
Wow
he was employed full-time at pensions
consulting firm while he had a no-frills
supermarket as a clerk and did freelance
writing on weekends and at night so
while people were out having a good time
I was usually inside on my computer
working to cut costs he rented out his
three-bedroom home lived in the basement
riding his bike to work eating craft
dinners and macaroni and cheese beans
and rice and beans like we say the
result is he paid off his two hundred
fifty five thousand dollar mortgage in
three years in two months
way to go Shawn it's an achievement many
would be proud of but some did not like
Cooper's industriousness and we're
scathing of his frugal lifestyle quote
upstanding citizen works his life away
lives in miserable squalor forgo human
relationships for years how is this an
inspirational story one man said on the
Facebook page digital courage by morons
in other words others didn't want to
applaud another example of white
privilege yet another privileged white
man what's this got to do with race
bragging about how he did it on his own
but did anyone notice how big
his downpayment was or the fact he had a
$75,000 full-time job he paid off two
hundred fifty five thousand three years
let me tell you what color this is green
you morons unbelievable
Oh stupid liberals unbelievable even his
work ethic had some fired up so he took
three jobs when people are struggling to
get one so as the lady said so he took
three jobs when other people are
struggling to get one so that he can pay
his debt off faster while others are
trying to find a job
and they struggled well I think we know
why you didn't get a job or some got
even more personal and it goes down here
from others I mean others wondered if he
lied and that helped and everything else
to go back and explain I didn't get an
inheritance I paid for my university all
myself so I certainly wasn't given a
free ride my mother was a single mother
I paid her $600 a month to rent when I
was living in her basement saving up the
downpayment he acknowledged the social
life was a problem but he paid a price
to win and on and on and on
became this big argument because the guy
wanted to manage his money in his life
his way and it offended a bunch of
victims out there and so we thought I
mean I read the article on the air
whenever it was a few months or a few
weeks back I don't remember five six
weeks ago when he came out and gave him
a big high-five just through the
airwaves and it turns out that Shawn had
never had the opportunity to do his debt
free scream for 11 and a half million
people in the Dave Ramsey show so James
our producer reached out and found him
and we've got him on the line in Toronto
Canada hey Sean how are you man
I'm doing really well how are you Dave
better than I deserve
I for one want to tell you my brother
congratulations I think you're a stud
thank you very much that was a really
great intro you're incredible man coming
were you a little shocked at how
ridiculously negative some people have
been yes I mean I guess I was shocked
with how much popularity the story gone
but I mean it definitely surprised me
that so many people
were kind of I guess against what I had
done I'm you know would have thought
people would be happy but there are so
many people out there I guess trolls you
want to call them that yeah I'm not so
nice things to say yeah especially in
comments with on Facebook when they
don't have to have a encourage and they
never have the guts to say it to your
face because they've only heard good
things to my face yeah I'll bet you know
we teach you people to get out of debt
all the time sometimes what people walk
through two three four years of paying
off their debts and you know working
extra jobs doing the stuff you do the
kraft mac and cheese the beans and rice
rice and beans and and i often ask them
how many people made fun of you and they
always say oh yeah guys at work gave me
a hard time but usually it's fairly good
natured ribbing some of this stuff was
just plain mean man exactly but i mean i
hope the people can be inspired by my
story to follow in my footsteps I mean
they don't have to necessarily pay off
their house in three years but if they
can set some themselves some sort of
financial goals to get out of debt then
I think that's the positive message to
take from my story absolutely cool well
we're honored to get to speak to you
today so uh have you been familiar with
our whole debt free process of us
teaching people yes I mean I've
definitely read up on your steps and
they're great steps to help people get
their finances in order so I mean I'm
definitely following all your steps and
I'm happy to have my mortgage paid off
well we're proud for you on that
but I guess what I'm talking about is is
we wanted to give you the opportunity to
do a tradition we have around here when
people work their tails off and get out
of debt we give them the opportunity to
yell at the top of their lungs I'm debt
free that's kind of how it sounds okay
and so we wanted to call you up and give
you that opportunity would you like to
do that yes I'm just on my office now
but I'll try to do as long as I can all
right brother
it's an honor to talk to you and our
congratulations to you we think you're a
fine human being thank you all right
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream from Shawn Cooper Toronto Canada
I'm debt free
that's perfect Shawn well done good job
dude well it's good to talk to you sir
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show I want to write a song I want
to own my own business I want to make
more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year to wish